more in this thread no there's not that
there was another video of him out there
bragging about i love the january 6.
it's like one big [ __ ]
treasonous circle jerk okay
let's go to the trendy trends in the
tweets god damn we're 35 minutes in and
i haven't even got to a trend yet so
let's go straight to kyle ridden house
god damn he's all the way up at number
two casey case i'm coming here at number
two kyle rittenhouse is a [ __ ]
murderer
kyle rittenhouse is a [ __ ] murderer
but
but the judge says
in the kyle rittenhouse trial the judge
says
we can't use the words victim for the
people that he murdered that would be
completely unfair to kyle rittenhouse
how would he ever live with himself
if he knew that he victimized people by
murdering them with a [ __ ] gun
so apparently the judge wants them to be
called writers and looters and arsonists
you know give him that real
race kind of tinge you know black lives
matter because that's going to be the
[ __ ] narrative that's going to be the
narrative that's it
that's it he went he went to stop bad
people
kyle rittenhouse was barney fife and
doing a citizen's arrest
and those people threatened him so he
had to mow them down with a rifle that
he took there and with the intent to
kill them
[ __ ] idiots
get the [ __ ] who is this judge who is
this guy
girl gal who the [ __ ] is the judge
are they a voted judge do they get voted
in because if they get voted in they
need to be [ __ ] voted out for sure
[ __ ] white supremacist [ __ ]
whoever this is
defending kyle rittenhouse
he murdered
other human beings
and that somehow he won't get a fair
trial because he shot him down in cold
blood and you can't say that they were
victims get the [ __ ] out of here
tara says as long as kyle rittenhouse is
getting a completely fair and impartial
trial
yeah well
[ __ ] ridiculous
well you can't call them you can't call
them victims because that would be
unfair to the person who murdered them
oh it would be so unfair to the person
that's on trial for murdering those
people that they would be called victims
of murder
oh my god how would kyle rittenhouse
ever manage
in life
get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] how ridden house and [ __ ] that
judge uh [ __ ] them let's see uh
there was some more trending topics they
may have they may have dropped off
because i was
you know um carrying on and on and on
about these videos